it's a dramatic change to say the least
in new orleans the spot where a statue
of robert e lee once stood is now home
to this depiction of an african deity
the installation by acclaimed sculptor
simone lee is part of prospect new
orleans it's a once every three-year
event that invites contributions from
artists the world over the exhibitions
are usually temporary but that's
something else that's seeing a big
change this time around
on a downtown new orleans traffic circle
once cradling the confederacy
something new and bold is taking a stand
and being serenaded
[Music]
it's sculptor simone lee's west african
deity mommy wata
her expression of healing i'm big on
public art
being public medicine
so what this is is medicine for
all of us
it's also controversial
beside the pedestal where five years
earlier a statue of confederate general
robert e lee was removed 60 percent of
new orleans is african-american is black
and so to have a black female figure at
the center of the city i hope says that
you can be inspired by this female
figure but also that how much of an
impact black culture has had on the city
in both the formation of the city but
also the continued life and the
continued energy of the city and we
really wanted to show diversity of work
so it's not just about drawings naima
keith is co-curator of prospect new
orleans along with partner diana nawi
they are the first team of women to
organize the triennial art exhibition
the showcases art in various museums and
public spaces around the city the art
itself spans from replica houses
to paintings of the insurrection
how did you coordinate this so help me
understand what you were doing as a
curator we began a kind of year-long
what we call the listening tour kind of
engaging
elders culture bearers stakeholders
artists creatives throughout the city to
kind of hear what was important about
this show and what they thought it could
do for the city this prospect is sure to
have a lasting impact in another way the
project was awarded a two million dollar
grant from the mellon foundation to
create a new age of monuments we really
wanted to propose a set of artists that
complicated this idea of monument when
one thinks of monument they often think
of a person right that you're kind of
putting a certain person in stone but
not here take e.j hill's work
memorializing the amusement park lost
during hurricane katrina the lone
surviving gondola from jazz land's
ferris wheel now rests in a nearby
neighborhood in new orleans east as we
invite artists to the city of new
orleans to make work about new orleans
they're also making work about the
issues that affect new orleans the most
climate change social justice these are
issues that affect all of us prospect
board chair chris alfieri has been a
leading force in the exhibition since
its inception in 2006. the initial
thought was it can
help promote the economy it can create
tourism what is it you hope it will be
well it really creates visibility for
new orleans around the world they've
taken that involvement a step further
with an installation that was simply
land when you went to prospect he said
this is my vision what was your reaction
i mean
they're you know i give them a lot of
credit because they were very open to
the idea but they had a million
questions
artist kevin beasley whose works have
graced the whitney the museum of modern
art and the guggenheim creates out of
this long island studio he never set
foot in new orleans before his prospect
invitation
the weight of that city is so
immense that
i wanted to do something that uh that
wasn't there for just three months i
think a lot of people would ask
what does
buying a plot of land
have to do with artistic expression it's
a big question i think given that the
premise was to think about what land
ownership black land ownership
specifically the lower ninth ward was a
predominantly black owned community
to this day
large portions of the lower ninth ward
remain barren many owners haven't
returned since katrina or have been
bought out by speculators and outsiders
as a newcomer beasley believes the
garden purchase with this prospect
stipend can welcome neighbors in small
subtle ways he even outfitted the lot
with wi-fi and electrical outlets to
charge phones it's a continual
living
piece of art in your mind yep exactly
that
that that it's not only a
project that people can experience now
but it's one that they can come back to
and see its evolution a promise of a
community for a city trying to define
what it was
is
and hopes to be a lot of exhibitions
triennial biennial exhibitions are
really bringing artists into a city and
then they leave that's not what our
artists do our artists get their hands
and feet in the city of new orleans
and sometimes never leave and this
exchange of not just
artwork but ideas innovation and quite
frankly um
neighborhood community is is what this
is really all about you gotta have your
hands and feet in if it's gonna be i
mean good right no you're connected to
the to the arts yeah new orleans
certainly needed prospect uh in 2007
when it first initiated 2006 and seven
but um it has done so much for the art
community and sort of put it on a map in
many ways cool thanks michelle thank you